[Music]
the sights and sounds of chuso a
mid-autumn Harvest Festival fill the air
in Soul the celebration is also known as
the Korean
Thanksgiving chok is a day when families
gather eat delicious food and spend
quality time together I think it's
wonderful many people are taking
advantage of the holiday to enjoy
cultural activities around the
city when it's chuk we seek our
traditional things I think wearing a
hbook is one of the most traditional
things to
do it's also a time for honoring
ancestors with prayers and
offerings in jingat park in the Border
City of paju is dedicated to families
separated by the Korean War nearly
134,000 people had registered with the
unification Ministry in the late 1980s
for State arranged family reunion events
with North Korea but that number is
diminishing with only around 40,000
people still alive many are in their 80s
or
older when the war broke out I was in my
hometown in Kong County in the north I
fled to the South my parents and older
sister stayed behind I applied several
times for family reunions but was never
Chosen and I never managed to get in
touch with my parents and sister I
assume they've passed away so every year
I come here family reunion participants
are chosen using a lottery system the
last event was in 2018 and with inter
Korean relations at a low there's little
hope one will be held soon hoping to
ease the pain of Separation the
government has created virtual towns
using the testimonies from people who
left the north 70 years
ago our hometown had blossoming Mountain
sides Clear Water beautiful scenery and
warmhearted
neighbors Kim OA is from Pyongyang and
dreamt of becoming a professional dancer
it's wonderful to see my hometown
recreated like this but while technology
brings some comfort chusok remains a
Bittersweet time for separated families
a reminder of everyone and everything
they had to leave behind Florence Louie
Al jazer paju South
Korea make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer